how come for us my name is BA and today
we're gonna play cemetery dreams you
must remember this game ah please game a
long time ago and I thought it would be
fun to maybe revisit some some of the
classics
there I am alright I'm the blue one
don't don't [ __ ] me yeah yeah what do
you say about my mom that she's a
beautiful lady
well you're absolutely right ah oh it
ain't over [ __ ]
I ain't over till I say it's off got
jelly
okay my [ __ ] guy set up for one
[ __ ] second don't touch me I'm
walking here alright
hey Cubs ah dick dick dick dick dick
dance I'm dancing up dis damn it
how do you control schemes ridiculous
now's my chance now say yeah that's
right [ __ ]
see you later boom wow my first one to
the table don't need to do the dishes
here we go nailed it oh you [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] you now
nah yes right boy you're my hood now
[ __ ] what are you doing Bernie why
don't we just have a nice little dinner
pills I don't want it
I'm gonna kill myself Bernie because you
don't love me all right let's go I'll
just be with that pole here Nick oh oh
oh oh oh coming for that ass coming for
that ass come on give me that ass boy
give me that ass boy yours
oh all of it okay I'm gonna go straight
for the attack now
oh that was sick breath that was sick
babe
I never liked you pony you white
privilige misogynist son of a [ __ ]
goddamnit don't Bernie we can walk this
we can work this out
damn it oh you want to do that Bernie
alright Bernie Oh Bernie
don't touch my legs oh I can I think
Bernie came Bernie what are you going
we're not nearly finished come back here
damn it Bernie you always finish too
fast
ah : amber lamps Colin ah ah I broke my
ass give it a sweet ass come on man yeah
that's right come on give me that ass
yeah boy yeah boy yeah boy yeah a giant
Vespa Josh yeah no no no no no no no no
no no